señora presidenta de la asamblea
nacional y honorables asambleístas del
ecuador
[Aplausos]
excelentísimos jefes de estado de los
países amigos que hoy nos visitan en
este día
[Aplausos]
altas autoridades del ecuador
distinguidos enviados especiales y
miembros del honorable cuerpo
diplomático y organismos internacionales
querida maría lourdes
queridos hijos
hermanos y familia un saludo al gabinete
entrante y a los amigos que hoy me
acompañan
un saludo al pueblo ecuatoriano en este
glorioso día
señoras y señores
hoy
estamos 24 de mayo del 2021
exactamente a un año del bicentenario de
la batalla del pichincha
la última de varias gestas que
consagraron la independencia de nuestra
nación y que dieron inicio a nuestro
trayecto hacia la vida republicana
es un día de rememoración
pero sobre todo es un día de renovación
porque el gobierno que hoy nace tiene
ante sí la responsabilidad de liderazgos
hacia un nuevo siglo del republicanismo
ecuatoriano
hoy debemos examinar si a lo largo de
estos 200 años hemos estado a la altura
de esos ideales republicanos que nos
vieron nacer
si hemos hecho honor a aquellos
patriotas que al morir en las faldas del
pichincha le dieron la vida a este país
héroes que lucharon por ideas ilustradas
como el imperio de la ley la libertad
individual
y la hermandad entre seres humanos
yo pregunto
el país que hoy recibimos responde a la
grandeza de aquel sacrificio
especialmente en los últimos años se ha
gozado de libertad en ecuador han
imperado la ley y la independencia de
poderes
ha reinado la igualdad de oportunidades
los ecuatorianos me conocen como un
hombre de acción
saben que mido todo en función de los
resultados que muestra la realidad
porque solo esta revela si hemos tenido
el coraje de poner en práctica aquella
tarea que nos encargaron los fundadores
de nuestro estado
y la realidad dice claramente que no
no hemos estado a la altura
hoy recibimos un país con históricos
niveles de desempleo
un país que ha deslumbrado por su
incapacidad para hacer frente a una
pandemia brutal
pero que países en similares condiciones
encararon de forma más ordenada
eficiente y sobre todo libres de
corrupción
un país donde los culpables engordan sus
bolsillos mientras los más inocentes
ecuatorianos recién nacidos ni siquieran
pueden llenar sus estómagos donde los
indicadores de desnutrición crónica
infantil están entre los más altos de la
región
un país con lacerantes desigualdades
entre el mundo rural y el urbano
un país que le ha fallado a su juventud
en educación y en creación de
oportunidades
que mantiene en el más humillante olvido
a sus jubilados
donde ser mujer no es solo un factor de
desventaja sino de peligro existencial
hoy que estamos a las puertas de un
nuevo centenario de vida republicana yo
los invito a preguntarse por qué
porque vivimos esta realidad en ecuador
porque tenemos una tierra tan rica pero
ciudadanos tan pobres
porque disponemos de recursos naturales
tan abundantes pero vivimos en medio de
la escasez porque teniendo un suelo tan
fértil nuestra economía no produce
bienestar para quienes más lo necesitan
las preguntas pueden ser miles pero la
respuesta es sólo una
y siempre la misma
y es que nuestros gobernantes nos han
fallado
ellos no han sabido estar a la altura
del sacrificio de nuestra gente
verdadero ejemplo de trabajo ni tampoco
han sabido aprovechar los ingentes
recursos que la naturaleza nos ha dado
nos han fallado por la sencilla razón de
que traicionaron a nuestros principios
fundacionales
en medio de tantas rencillas y lucha
intestina se dieron a la peor de las
debilidades políticas
la tentación autoritaria
se dedicaron al obsceno oculto del
caudillo aquel mesías que supuestamente
todo lo sabe lo que está bien y lo que
está mal lo que nos conviene y lo que
nos perjudica un iluminado que actúa y
piensa por todos que tiene todas las
preguntas y también todas las respuestas
nunca han podido aceptar que este país
nació como una república democrática y
que su destino es vivir para siempre
como una república democrática
[Aplausos]
pero todo eso
cambia este 24 de mayo
en este gobierno que hoy nace en este
nuevo siglo de republicanismo que
estamos a punto de arrancar
termina la era de los caudillos
[Aplausos]
hoy
reivindicamos este día glorioso e
iniciamos la lucha para recuperar el
alma democrática de nuestro país
y eso empieza por las cosas más básicas
e incluso obvias pero que estamos
obligados a decir comienza por no
acumular más poder en la figura del
presidente de la república porque la
experiencia nos dice que quienes buscan
todo el poder luego terminan buscando
que mencias por los crímenes que ocurren
cuando ese poder se les va de las manos
nosotros
nos mantendremos fieles a los estrictos
márgenes que dictan las leyes vamos a
tener la humildad pero sobre todo la
fortaleza para decir
seré presidente
y solo presidente
no perseguiremos a nadie no callaremos a
nadie gobernaremos para todos
esto significa no gobernar a favor de un
sector privilegiado pero tampoco en
contra de nadie
tengan la opinión que tengan hagan la
crítica que hagan
alguien debe decir
esto acaba aquí
aun a sabiendas de los peligros
políticos que conlleva aun sabiendo que
otros estarían ya exhibiendo aquí en
este estrado una macabra lista de
enemigos y perseguidos del gobierno
alguien debe tener la valentía de asumir
el riesgo y romper el ciclo vicioso y en
este punto de la historia eso sólo lo
puede hacer este nuevo gobierno
[Aplausos]
por lo tanto
que así sea
se acabó la persecución política en el
ecuador yo no he venido a saciar el odio
de pocos si no he venido a saciar el
hambre de muchos
[Aplausos]
seré
el jefe democrático
de un estado democrático mi fuerza no
nacerá de cuán alto alce la voz para
gritar sino de cuánto escucharé al
pueblo antes de hablar
detrás de las ruinas
del culto al caudillo se empieza a
construir una democracia que use el
poder limitado por las leyes para ser
más grandes los sueños de todos los
ciudadanos
una democracia donde nadie se ha
señalado como vendepatrias o enemigo de
la patria y cuyos únicos enemigos sean
la enfermedad el analfabetismo la
desnutrición la violencia de género ese
es el mandato del 11 de abril último
muchos me preguntan cómo logramos que
aquel día se diera el gran cambio
pacífico que ha maravillado al
continente
y me atrevo a decir también al mundo
la respuesta es muy sencilla lo que
sucedió fue la democracia en sí misma
luego de más de 10 años de autoritarismo
de agresiones de intentos por instaurar
un régimen perpetuo los ecuatorianos
asimilamos la más grande elección
democrática
que no hay democracia sin participación
de los ciudadanos
hoy los ciudadanos queremos dar queremos
contribuir sin pedir nada más que la
esperanza de hacer un mejor país
queremos que nuestro voto signifique un
país más justo con las mujeres
un país más responsable con la
naturaleza un país más equitativo con
los más necesitados
que todos los políticos de este país se
acostumbren a que la política gestó un
deseo fundamental de los ciudadanos por
contribuir al bien común al bien
colectivo
que esta democracia que hoy recordamos
sea para siempre un torrente donde la
gente aglutina sus ideales
cada uno más admirable y valioso que
otro
y que juntos esos ideales sirvan para
construir un país diverso
donde todos tengamos tendremos cabida
así más de 14 años después y a las
puertas de un nuevo siglo de vida
republicana en ecuador aprendimos
que solo hay una respuesta posible ante
el autoritarismo
y esta es democracia
democracia y más democracia
todos decidimos ahogar el mal en la
abundancia del bien
ese es el camino ecuatoriano el camino
correcto sabemos que no nos equivocamos
porque las democracias desarrolladas no
se han equivocado
sus grandes avances en bienestar
económico en salud de educación
demuestran que no se han equivocado y
por más grande que será la presión para
reemplazar nuestra aún débil
institucionalidad con la violencia de
los gritos no nos desviaremos ni un
milímetro del camino trazado
no cederemos porque eso sería hacer un
daño mayor
aquel ciclo vicioso se acaba hoy
y hoy se inicia el camino al ecuador del
encuentro
nosotros llevamos el espíritu del
encuentro en el nombre de nuestro país
ecuador somos tierra donde se unen
hemisferios regiones climas y culturas
somos los herederos de un encuentro de
civilizaciones que cambió para siempre
el curso de la humanidad somos
depositarios de saberes ancestrales de
esta tierra y que en el tiempo se han
fundido con las culturas que llegaron
desde el viejo mundo buscando libertad
pero toda esa historia debe convertirse
en un futuro más justo 'ecuador debe
significar también una promesa de
equilibrio en la vida común equilibrio
entre las causas de su gente equilibrio
entre el crecimiento económico y la
justicia social dos piedras angulares
que serán las bases de un país próspero
y equitativo
un país donde todos los niños puedan
cultivar sus mentes sin importar sus
condiciones de origen donde los jóvenes
tendrán libertad para reflexionar y
buscar la vocación que mejor desarrolle
sus espíritus sin presiones y sin temor
al fracaso donde la prosperidad material
signifique también la limpieza de
nuestro aire la limpieza de nuestros
bosques y la limpieza de nuestros mares
[Aplausos]
y es que el encuentro
no es un concepto abstracto es ante todo
la certeza de que las causas de este
gobierno serán las causas de la gente de
los ciudadanos de todas las mujeres de
los jóvenes de los trabajadores de los
obreros
que la voluntad del gobierno será la
voluntad del pueblo movido por los
mismos objetivos y las mismas esperanzas
más que un sueño serán acciones
dirigidas por un estado eficiente para
erradicar el hambre la enfermedad la
falta de educación y el abandono
que no haya dudas nuestra intención no
es minimizar el estado sino maximizar su
capacidad para servir a los más pobres
[Aplausos]
hace poco
hace poco más de 40 años el presidente
jaime roldós aguilera
ya nos exigía
agua quiere el pueblo el pueblo quiere
agua
el tiempo ha pasado varios gobiernos han
ido y venido pero los problemas
permanecen
el primer punto donde debemos
encontrarnos es en nuestra ruralidad
donde nuestros hermanos del campo sufren
aún más la escasez de servicios como
agua potable y alcantarillado
al rememorar un año más de la prematura
partida del presidente roldós hacemos
muestras sus palabras retomamos su
proceso promesa agua agua para el pueblo
y no solo agua sino también
infraestructura esencial como vialidad
alumbrado escuelas y hospitales
otro punto de encuentro es reconocer que
la lucha por la igualdad de género no es
un problema sólo de las mujeres
es un problema nacional un problema
ecuatoriano que debe ser abordado por el
gobierno ecuatoriano
[Aplausos]
cuando el desempleo
afecta más a la mujer que al hombre
cuando una mujer ecuatoriana gana menos
por el mismo trabajo que un hombre se
produce una inequidad que desgarra el
tejido social empezando por las familias
y cuando una mujer ecuatoriana es
agredida
las heridas las sufrimos todos nos
convierten en un país menos libre menos
justo y moralmente manchado
los derechos de las mujeres
y derechos humanos y pondremos en marcha
todas las políticas necesarias para
garantizarlos
[Aplausos]
otro punto de encuentro
es la erradicación del hambre
especialmente la desnutrición infantil
es esta quizás la peor de las
desigualdades porque sus consecuencias
perduran en el tiempo en los problemas
de crecimiento que padecerán miles de
niños que actualmente no reciben
alimentación adecuada
la imperdonable inacción de hoy nos está
costando el mañana pero el momento llegó
para actuar este país te encuentro
protegerá por igual a todos sus niños
nazcan donde nazcan
el encuentro se construye también con la
confianza que estamos generando en el
mundo después de muchos años
el planeta vuelve a poner los ojos en el
ecuador
tan solo al producirse la noticia de
nuestra elección del riesgo-país se
redujo en más de 500 puntos
aun antes de posicionarnos se concretó
una de las tareas de cualquier gobierno
crear una atmósfera positiva para el
trabajo y el crecimiento
pero esta renovada confianza debe
comprometernos a todos
especialmente a quienes dentro del
ecuador tienen la capacidad para
emprender y crear empleo
desde ya los convocamos a iniciar sin
miedos la reactivación económica
aquí está la oportunidad esperada
demuestren que sin acosos sin
persecuciones están listos para poner
sus recursos al servicio de la sociedad
ecuatoriana y no y no
al país al servicio de sus recursos
demuestren su compromiso nacional
parafraseando unas palabras del
presidente kennedy
mientras como país no podamos ayudar a
los pobres
este gobierno no podrá ayudar a los más
ricos
[Aplausos]
hay otro punto de encuentro que durante
demasiado tiempo ha sido eludido
y se encuentra más allá de nuestra
frontera las últimas dos décadas
han sido una época de maravillosos
cambios tecnológicos en el mundo
atravesamos una fascinante era de
invención que ha vuelto obsoletas varias
nociones del pasado
y mientras el mundo moderno se hacía más
pequeño avanzando en conectividad en
comercio y educación digital en el
ecuador nos decían que debíamos
encerrarlo que debíamos hacer más
difícil que nuestro talento salga a
competir en el mundo
pero la realidad es que ningún país
puede vivir aislado todos estamos
conectados de la misma forma que ningún
ser humano puede vivir sin ser parte de
una familia y de una sociedad
asimismo un país no puede darle la
espalda a la familia de naciones que
conforman el mundo el aislamiento el
encierro sólo conduce a la decadencia
como país cubrimos un territorio
relativamente pequeño
pero el talento de nuestra gente es
infinito
es hora de un liderazgo con una visión
grande
[Música]
grande como las capacidades de sus
ciudadanos
hoy el ecuador declara que abre sus
puertas al comercio mundial
[Aplausos]
buscaremos estar presentes en el menor
tiempo posible en la alianza del
pacífico como un país como un socio de
pleno derecho
abriremos al ecuador a tratados de libre
comercio con nuestros más grandes
aliados nos insertaremos plenamente en
el mundo para buscar un comercio libre y
justo
más ecuador en el mundo
y más mundo en ecuador
en el mundo habitan 7 mil 400 millones
de habitantes ahí está la gran
oportunidad del ecuador para vender el
talento ecuatoriano los productos
ecuatorianos y ese mundo tiene un ahorro
sustancialmente infinitamente mayor para
invertir en ecuador de lo que podemos
tener localmente ahí está la gran
oportunidad el mundo
que el mundo sepa también que estamos
comprometidos con los principales
consensos internacionales para alcanzar
el desarrollo sostenible en 2015 fue
adoptada la declaración
transformar nuestro mundo agenda 2030
para el desarrollo sostenible acuerdo
que coincide en que todas las personas
necesitamos de salud educación vivienda
empleo energía igualdad paz y
ecosistemas sanos para vivir dignamente
el principio es no dejar a nadie atrás
lo que pone a la inclusión de los
ciudadanos como la prioridad de nuestras
tareas
todos son objetivos que este gobierno
comparte y activamente impulsará
el desarrollo sostenible parte de la
erradicación de la pobreza en todas sus
formas la lucha contra la desigualdad
la preservación del planeta el
crecimiento económico sostenido y el
fomento de la inclusión social
debemos incluir a los marginados del
progreso
los más pobres de entre los pobres
a lo largo de mis 12 años de recorrido
político en el ecuador
he podido conocer a muchas mujeres
algunas madres adolescentes otras madres
abandonadas por sus esposos
a cargo de dos de tres hijos viviendo
con un dólar al día o jugando al bingo
en las tardes para ver si ganas y comes
cuando la mayoría pierde y no come
yo me comprometí con una de ellas
me comprometí con lorenza a quien le
dije lorenza el día que yo llegué al
poder tú estarás ahí en mi corazón en mi
mente en mi alma y serán tú y todas las
mujeres del ecuador
el símbolo de nuestra lucha
pero es que no solo conozco a lorenza
conozco a las mujeres del barrio katia
de machala
aquellas mujeres del barrio la laguna de
quevedo del pescador de huaquillas de
los guasmos de la trinitaria de nigeria
de cenepa
cantidades de mujeres excluidas de las
oportunidades en ecuador
no podía dejarlas de mencionar
debo ser leal con los ciudadanos
aquellos que han confiado en mí y
esperan un verdadero cambio en el
ecuador
para generar oportunidades para las
mujeres necesitamos cambiar la
orientación de las políticas públicas
con el fin
de impulsar su inclusión social su
desarrollo